It is time for hatred at mail with a very
special new Corona virus related hatred. Male
introduction. Let's take a listen. What is
hatred at male?
If you're allowed to shop for luxuries like
food and medicine, then we should be allowed
to clap our hands together in a mega-church.
Teary eyed man written by patriots who hate
David Pakman because America and because freedom.
All right. Love that I've actually have two
new hatred are a coronavirus themed intros.
We'll play the next one next week. I think
you'll like it. Let's get right into it. This
week's edition of Hatred Mail. It goes after
you. It goes after our audience and our followers
and our subscribers. Take a listen.
I want fraiche. But being losers in this channel
get a real job that offers real insurance.
G.T. AFO of your lazy asses b t w Trump is
still your president. O David Pakman is a
user and you'll fall for it. Sheep Pakman
failed utterly. You are less than nothing.
And also subscribers. Seriously 800k. Who
are these morons? Count me out.
Listen, go after me. I can take it. I'm a
big boy. Don't go after our subscribers. And
by the way, if you're going to state the correct
number of subscribers, we are not at 800000
subscribers. In fact, that last check. We
are almost at eight hundred twenty six thousand
subscribers on YouTube. We're at 33000 on
Twitch. We're at one hundred and twenty thousand
on Facebook. We have a combined 200000 followers
on Twitter.
So, yes, the numbers are growing and it's
thanks to you. And I'm so appreciative of
that. And it seems the hatreds are getting
very, very triggered. You know, for years
I've been dealing with hate messages that
say, David, I'm so glad your show is circling
the drain. David, I'm so glad you will soon
be gone and your views are being reduced to
zero. And fortunately, and this is not because
of me. It's because of you. Things have gone
in the opposite direction. And we're really
so grateful. And we're gonna do sort of like
a state of the show update coming up at some
point soon where I'm going to talk you through
all of the different things that have been
going on with the show. And some of them are
very, very exciting. A lot. To quote our president.
A lot of them are very exciting. In the meantime,
fight hatred, autism by using the code Hatra
at 40. When you get a membership on my Web
site, the coupon code HKT are I o t for zero.
Will save you 40 percent off of any membership
at join packman dot com.